[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Hello.
We often get questions
from companies
about how to
document and transfer
their API program's knowledge
across attributed teams.
Enter the API Playbook.
The API Playbook is
a living document
that guides the overall
direction of your API program.
When we consider the
digital value chain,
every aspect is an integral
part of the API Playbook.
For example, how do you
ensure your APIs are secure?
What processes will you have in
place to connect your back end
services to your applications?
And how will you engage
your community and customers
to ensure your API
program is successful?
These questions and others
all need to be answered.
The playbook describes
your approach
to API management as a whole.
It includes the essential
standards that all APIs must
follow for an organization,
the best practices
for designing APIs, in a common
and consumer friendly fashion,
and the essential
ways of working
for API producing teams to
boost quality APIs at speed
and scale.
Your playbook should
focus on six key areas,
your organization, best
practices, API design
decisions, development
requirements, API management
and deployment processes, and
overall support guidelines.
This should be a
living document,
derived from industry
best practices,
and best of all, experience
of people inside your company.
Here's a condensed
summary of various items
that will appear in a playbook.
Every business is unique.
And as a result,
every API Playbook
is also unique to that business.
Let's take a closer look
at the core topics and what
information you may
find in each section.
In this section, APIs
in your organization
explains how API governance,
ownership, and federation
works.
It's important to stress who
and how APIs will be managed
as well as what types of APIs
are in your organization,
as well as what API teams
and roles should be,
and what they do.
Your guideline and guiding
principle to follow here
is as you move towards a
comprehensive API program,
you should have an API first
mandate from leadership.
Direct your digital product
owners and API teams
to own their APIs and leverage
a common infrastructure
with common design
patterns that flow
throughout the
entire organization.
Successful APIs require
more than good technology.
You'll need to
ensure your team is
equipped with the right
people and processes.
Traditional development
processes, or waterfall project
management, simply
doesn't work when
a team has to respond to
opportunities, feedback,
or problems quickly.
This section covers
best practices
for organization using
agile development for APIs.
Outline your software
development lifecycle,
how your teams will
maintain quality assurance,
and what strategies you'll
focus on for mocking your data,
and how all of these ways of
working might be automated.
Your guiding principle
here is simple.
Successful teams
are agile, nimble,
and leverage automation.
And a large enterprise,
many different lines
of businesses and API teams
will be producing APIs.
And it's a slippery slope
of discordant design
if we don't all follow
the similar guidelines.
This section details the
important aspects of your API
design and helps to
guide a consistent look
and feel and function of all
the APIs in your catalog.
Your guiding principle, your API
should be designed as products
with an outside
in view, allowing
developers and consumers to
easily read and understand
your data.
In the development section
of your API playbook,
document how you'll
facilitate security as well
as other patterns
and policies which
are required in the enterprise.
Provide guidance on how user
authentication will be managed
as well as any other
policies for logging,
transformation,
or orchestration.
These are often mandatory
development guidelines
regardless of what the
functionality the API exposes.
You're guiding principle here
is to provide reusable shared
flows, assets,
and other patterns
designed to help your API
teams go to market faster.
In this section, we
detailed the configurations
necessary for a successful
pathway to production.
It should outline each step
of your continuous integration
and delivery process
and the tools used.
Furthermore, it list
each environment and what
that environment is used for.
You can also include
lists of analytics reports
that will help support
auditing, governance, marketing,
and ongoing development.
You should also include
steps to prepare
technical and non-technical
documentation for the developer
portal.
Your guiding principle here
is your software development
lifecycle should
be tightly coupled
with continuous
integration and delivery
tools that manage your APIs
from coding, to deployment,
to monitoring, and analysis.
In your support section, explain
how your developer portal
will be used to manage.
Discuss how you will
support your community
with documentation around
FAQs, troubleshooting,
support steps, and resources you
might make available to them.
Investing the time to
create a good resource
and support workflows
will pay dividends
when it comes to
both your customers
and your own
organization's time.
Your guiding principle, your
consumers are your customers.
And a good customer experience
is a critical factor
for building useful APIs.
A thriving community
will ultimately
help your API program to
grow and become successful.
Hopefully, you now
have a solid outline
to build your
first API Playbook.
If you want more
information, please check out
the community for
ebooks, articles,
and other related topics.
Thank you for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]